there are tons of videos online of
people getting chased by bears a lot of
them are real but some of them are fake
that would be some triple a tier quality
work this is a hundred percent real
that's no there's
[Applause]
hey how's it going welcome back to
another episode of vfx artist debunk
that's right that's our new show name i
like it i i just decided right now it's
probably not our show welcome back to
the bunken brothers
okay listen so i saw something on reddit
that made me do a quadruple take i'm not
sure if it's real or fake i've been
seeing a lot of buzz about this and a
lot of the comments are like oh that's
definitely fake if i look at the pixels
i can tell
first off let's just go ahead and watch
it yeah fair
[Music]
because it's a sweet drone shot flying
up and over the trees like that's a shot
that i'd be pretty happy with
look at this dude flying by uh
and the bear wait hold on a sec
what i love about this is that dude that
double take from the bear this is a
hundred percent real that's no
that would be some
aaa tier quality work for a random video
on reddit i don't know what if this is
like a resume for someone in the visual
effects industry but hit us up because
we're impressed
that's insane that's so good let's say
this bear is a cgi bear it's visual
effects what is the thing that stands
out to you as the most challenging thing
that this video does flawlessly here's
the trickiest thing in my opinion this
is the very first thing i looked for
when i saw the shot and that is the
bear's shadow against the other shadows
on the ground yeah that exact thing so
you have real snow snow acts a lot like
alabaster or marble or milk or candles
it's a medium where the light goes
through it and scatters they're almost
like volumetric shadows like shadows and
fog so shadows take on this like depth
to them they have this fuzziness around
the edges and the light propagates the
snow in certain ways and then if you're
going to project another shadow on top
of that well you need to cut out those
other shadows so that your shadows don't
double up because that's not how shadows
work if you look the bear's shadow is
not on top of the tree shadows it's the
same light being of spirit that the
trees are obscuring so that's the thing
that would be effectively impossible to
do unless they actually had the entire
ground bcg notice how the shadow
actually deforms over the terrain of the
snow perfectly too perfectly while also
then combining with the existing shadows
flawlessly there's no like sort of blend
mark which is an artifact that you can
tend to get when you try to do that sort
of proper blending it's that more than
anything else that convinces me this is
real i will say watching this the
plausibility around just why this clip
exists like checks all my boxes like i
think it's pretty clearly like on their
farm of some sort i don't think the
guy's running for his life from the bear
the guy does not look freaked out it
feels like it was a clip that was
produced to be funny it feels set up in
that way but certainly not in a way that
like the bear is cg because there's so
many different elements here the shadows
are perfect the footprints in the snow
you're talking fur simulation you're
talking snow kick up particle simulation
even the way the bear looks back is the
drone flies by naturally like something
would if something's like flipping
perfect animation perfect animation
animation the way it stops and it reacts
to the ground like one of the problems
with physics systems and visual effects
is it's hard to get them to feed back
into each other because at a certain
point you're in a feedback loop it's one
of the issues they had with king kong
when he's on the boat is when king kong
moves that would cause the boat to rock
which would cause king columns as a
creature to adjust their balance which
would cause the boat to rock which
caused them to adjust their balance when
you throw it into a computer it goes
and it dies
because it just feedback loops so at a
certain point the artists were like we
will animate the boat and then you guys
can drive the animation of king kong
based on that and sure do physics for
the hair there are to some degree like
ways to get these things to interact and
feedback to each other and interact with
each other on a simulation level but
yeah when we're talking about animation
that's a whole different ballpark where
that feedback loop would break it i'm
almost thinking looking at this it would
be simpler to just make the entire
environment and bare cg so that
everything works in tandem but now all
of a sudden
yeah don't worry about sam he's looking
for project loon i need to figure out
the secrets of logic blue
but yeah it's almost to the point where
the entire environment would benefit
from being cg but then you have the guy
that ruins that too so all these things
together it's just if you're talking the
effort put in to make this real which i
don't even think is possible versus the
reward of one post on reddit doesn't
make any sense yeah this requires making
your own software level of like realism
this is like i'm going to write my own
program from scratch to do this all
right wait hold on before we move on
didn't somebody reach out and follow up
with us on project loon like an actual
flight path yeah it's pretty crazy we
have a video on crew cuts on
quarterdigital.com where we go into the
after story of that if you wanted to
know more about the ufo video go check
it out quarterdigital.com our crew cuts
show so i decided to look into this a
little bit more and there's a bit of a
rabbit hole here there's no information
about this clip and the information that
people are able to find was disappearing
from the internet rapidly there's a fpv
pilot that did share this video with the
hashtag mavic and hashtag djv now i at
first thought djv was a typo trying to
say dji you know they make drones but
djv is apparently a visual effects
review software hashtag djv doesn't
automatically mean they're talking about
an obscure visual effects review
software aka a video viewer with
commenting abilities like it could be a
million things there's a snopes episode
that's written about this that claims
that this is vfx in other words all of
this pointed to the idea that the video
showed a clever mix of cgi bear with a
background video shot by a drone wrong
they're wrong i'm inclined to agree
because this seems more like a trained
bear in my mind it's a trained bear guys
it is in my personal opinion this is
definitely a real shot yeah there's zero
evidence in this not a single shred of
pixels that point to this being visual
effects yeah every piece of evidence
sits firmly on the other side of that
argument part of the mission of a lot of
our videos is to help kind of educate
the general audience about how visual
effects are done and how to not have
this mindset exhibit a this isn't no
crazy hollywood level expensive deal cgi
isn't as hard as people think nowadays i
work in video and could have my
post-production team replicate this in
maybe three hours on an old laptop stop
oh man just a few hours three hours on
an old
drone pilot slash videographer here you
wouldn't get that kind of clear audio
often
like this yeah
of course i've actually been very
surprised by how often i've seen the
sound comments like oh they replaced the
audio therefore this video is fake
that's step one in every visual effects
shot step one is always to replace the
audio when doing visual effects
is the first thing we do it is very
common practice to replace the audio
from a drone because it just sounds like
and so it's also very common to have
people sound design the shots little
sound elements like going by a creek you
hear the water the whoosh is going over
trees or dude going
well yeah i mean video clips don't just
upload themselves to the internet
somebody consciously produced and
delivered this clip online which you
know
the whole time it's like no the comment
that really
really got me here video is way too
low-res to make out the graphic details
but cgi is good enough at a consumer
level nowadays to fake this easy easily
oh okay maybe maybe he knows what he's
talking about let me read his next
sentence here rotoscope in the path with
a realistic model
add shaders and textures easy
that's it you just put a static model
there and then throw textures and
shaders out don't forget
you have the rotoscope that means
something yeah it means you know cut out
the path for some reason and then you
know the rest is easy this is a classic
example of someone who thinks they know
what they're talking about because they
know a few buzz words it's always
important to remind people of the
dunning-kruger effect when you learn a
little bit about something you suddenly
think that you're an expert in something
in other words you have not yet learned
how much you don't know you just learned
a little bit of stuff that now you do
know it happens to me all the time
every walk of life it happens to me as
well i feel like i start knowing
something but the key is to get to the
point where you start realizing how
little you know you know for
comparison's sake there are tons of
videos online of people getting chased
by bears a lot of them are real but some
of them are fake and i kind of wanted to
take a look at them to kind of show you
what we mean in some of the senses that
are tingling when we look at an actual
fake bear chase
hey guys it's me jake here out in the
woods because today i'm going to be
filming my first
viral bear chase hit now i would use
visual effects but i don't really know
how to do visual effects so i'm going to
do it the old-fashioned way where a bear
actually chases me i know it sounds kind
of dangerous but i've got everything
covered courtesy of today's sponsor
bessie i'm going to be wearing a pair of
vessy sneakers and that's going to get
me out of this alive okay and there they
are
oh wait oh
oh no
well okay it looks like i forgot them
back at the house let me run up there
and do
is that a bear right there oh god i was
just kidding i'm not actually going to
do a bear taste video i was there's no
there's actually a bear down here i i
was not prepared for this at all
jake
cake
it is i
bear here to tell you about today's
sponsor bessie
that's right keep running
vessels are comfortable stylish sneakers
you can wear every day i know you like
boots not anymore you like bessies
that's because vessies are made from an
incredible patented dimetex material
which will keep your feet cool in the
summer and warm in the winter and they
have anti-microbial insoles that keep
your feet fresh while cloud-like
cushioning keeps things comfy okay
oh god i wish i had fancies on i just
laughed a shoe did you know that vessies
are 100 waterproof and snow proof fesis
will have your feet dry in fall and
winter's unpredictable weather the thing
that i like most about bessie's is that
they're sustainably made and vegan not
only do they use less material waste and
less water waste they're not made from
any animal by-products that's right good
for me
good for you
good for bears now you might want to
harvest my pelt for a great winter coat
but i can assure you humans have
developed some very competitive
technologies that will keep your feet
and your body feeling comfortable
lightweight and breathable all the time
no more need to go out and harvest bear
pelts all you need is to get a pair of
vessies remember that vessels are a
great investment to wear all year long
for all different types of activities
and weather conditions had you been
wearing them here i probably wouldn't
even be chasing you
okay guys guys oh god
okay i found a little fort right here
i'm gonna hide in it i think the bear
still has my scent but
i should be out of here alive in just a
little bit i'll let you guys know um in
the meantime if you guys are interested
in getting a pair of besties for
yourself just click the link in the
description below and you'll get 25
off each pair of adult bessie shoes
that's 25 off each pair of adult vessy
shoes by going to vessie.com corridor
crew
okay oh no he's coming he's coming back
oh yeah that's the you can tell yeah
where'd it go is there more of it
oh yeah
yeah i mean
sure is the leaf not rotoscoped is the
leaf in the foreground behind the bear
in the background oh it's like a little
bit above the branches above them it
would have been actually pretty
convincing the motion tracking was good
you know the stock footage that he
grabbed was decent he really just needed
to work the colors i suppose just
letting it just be the raw footage the
color bothers me less than the luminance
intrinsically you kind of just get a
sense that the black levels aren't right
yeah just it's the darkest thing in the
entire frame yeah yeah by far so even
though we only see it for a split second
it just subconsciously feels like it
shouldn't be there and it's the shadow
again as the giveaway right like look at
that thing yeah i think it's dense
motion blur was the big one for me he
whips back and then whips back forward
again so quickly that you wouldn't be
able to actually see the bear there is
motion blur but there's just like one
frame where there's zero motion blur at
all and it sticks out even though we
only see it for a 30th of a second i
wonder if he specifically turned on a
sharp frame just so like we have that
like moment of seeing a bear i think the
reason there's a single frame of the
sharp there is because the motion blur
that's happening here is a
two-dimensional translation motion blur
and here we have rotational motion blur
we have jelly and skew happening from
within the sensor itself from the
rolling shutter we have compression
artifacts and like you can't get that
complexity of motion with your basic
two-dimensional after effects motion
blur you're just gonna get basic you
know uniform smears of the object and
that's it i'm not trying to dunk on this
person in their vfx motion tracking is
great and the idea is really funny and
honestly the cinematography is kind of
cool too we're just trying to point out
what you would actually need to look at
to make these effects look real in
reference to the very first video that
we all think is real let's look at the
best bear effects in hollywood and see
if those are at least on par with the
drum bear or the drum bear is even
better than the best that's ever come
out of hollywood so let's check out the
bear attack from the revenant
i know we've looked at the shot before
on vfx artists react but in this context
i think it's worth revisiting
oh my god in the plants
i forget about the plant interaction so
the very first thing that stands out to
me is while it's well animated it does
feel like it's animated it feels like
somebody's gotten in there they're kind
of working with motion capture of a
person and they're just an incredibly
talented animator but it still does not
quite have like that chaotic natural
randomness and weight shifting and
detail that just real life has it's
really close though i mean it's close
enough that when i watched the movie for
the first time i didn't really second
guess that this was a real bear you know
like i was watching a movie i was in it
yeah i believe this was a real bear when
i watched the movie it looks great right
there fantastic work and the the wet fur
is just like with all like the granular
chunks and friggin yeah yeah like the
bits in it
and to be clear this scene there's so
much more going on than just a cg bear
the fact that like leo dicaprio is
interacting with the bear like there's a
lot that has to be planned ahead of time
executed at an expert level and then all
of the rendering and compositing all the
simulations and whatnot all executing at
such a high level to get what we're
seeing here and you know if the team
that did this bear did a bear in a drone
shot the bear would probably look as
good as that bear in the drone shot but
it still has to go through the process
of compositing and that's still just
you're limited by physics to a certain
degree with compositing and that's where
it doesn't matter how good your cg is
the shadows ain't gonna paint out
themselves
you gotta still do that hand work
basically what we're learning here is
that the drone bear guy is way better
than this entire production on an old
laptop in a few hours so that's i mean
after effects
there's another video i want to take a
look at of this woman snowboarding down
a mountain with a bear chasing after her
and she's far too casual
oh let's see oh the bear fake there's
the baby
it was fake from the get-go i just tell
it's definitely a commercial and since
she's listening to music she can't hear
the bear chasing after her
i think you might maybe it is a
commercial for headphones you might be
right they're displayed beautifully
when i first saw this video i was like
oh that's scary
this is a great example of what
compositing a bear in behind you actual
footage of a bear would actually look
like yeah it's nice because you can only
really take the compositing elements so
far and they did a really nice job from
what i'm seeing here but you know there
are obvious elements that are not real
one of the first things that stands out
to me see right there the difference
between those few frames you see how
there's like an adjustment in the entire
environment it like goes muddier almost
like lowers in contrast for whatever
reason but the bear stays perfectly the
same the other big thing that stands out
to me is at the end of the day when you
use footage you're stuck with the
lighting of that footage the lighting
here in this scene is not top-down
lighting the ground and the sky are the
same brightness it's wraparound lighting
if you look at her jacket the bright
spots aren't the top of the jacket it's
the sides of the jacket where it's
reflecting the brightness of the snow so
the bears shouldn't be bright on the top
and dark on the bottom it should be
bright on the sides and dark in the
center but you know all in all for
having to cut out bare footage from an
entirely different source color grade it
try to match like the fogginess the
scene have snow popping up over the feet
it doesn't look that bad yeah
oh directed by there it is produced by
the wool shed company well maybe it's
not for the headphones but if this
wasn't that maybe if they're trying to
pretend it's an ad like showing we can
make viral videos did you see the
website it said dot com virals yeah half
a billion unpaid views and counting we
tricked people into watching your
advertisements oh they did the rolling
and the tire one oh wait they did that
lightning one too huh oh they did that
one too and that one
okay these guys are legit
while many of the videos you watch
probably don't have visual effects in
them to do a trick on you many of the
videos you watch are staged something
doesn't have to use vfx to be fake
staged i guess is a form of faking it
although i will say for how often stuff
just gets taken at face value on the
internet i mean just look at any of the
reposts of boss town dynamics it's nice
to have people taking something like
this and being like wait a minute maybe
it's not real skepticism's nice to see i
do like saying that we're getting some
skepticism here and you know what let's
be real part of the reason these people
are probably breaking it down as cgi is
because they probably watch the show and
watch us break things down to cgi so
we're partially to blame here in a good
way at least people are learning about
visual effects but just a reminder it's
still very very hard
[Laughter]
i think at the end of the day all i
gotta say is if you want more of this go
to captain disillusion he has a way
better take on it
he makes incredible stuff you like
debunking if you like skepticism if you
want to learn more check out his channel
so christian apparently set up an email
debunk at quarter digital if you have a
video aliens bigfoot loch ness monster
and preferably the actual files the raw
files none of this compressed like i got
recorded off the screen my phone stuff
but seriously if you have something you
want to take a look at debunk
quarterdigital.com thanks to all the
spam on youtube comments now we had to
like ban links in the comments so if you
recommend a video through a comment
you're not going to see it sorry
nick was saying that like we already
have a bunch of great ufo footage so you
know what that means subscribe for more
bunk-a-thons it's exciting i love this
i legitimately want to be wrong i want
to be wrong and i want to see you you
want to believe i want to believe i want
an unexplainable video yeah you want to
barely